find the perimeter of the parallelogram
and we have a parallelogram right over
here opposite sides are parallel that
side is parallel to that side right over
here this side is parallel to that side
over here and also the parallelogram
opposite sides have the same length now
we have to worry about the perimeter
here which essentially just says if we
had a field the size or the shape of
this parallelogram and we wanted to make
a fence around the field that was the
shape of this parallelogram how long
would that fence have to be and
obviously you would be the length of the
sum of the lengths of the sides so and
we wouldn't even have to worry about
this thing right over here we could
ignore it for the sake of that problem
we don't care about the actual height or
this altitude right over here we just
care about the lengths of its sides so
the perimeter of this pet of this
parallelogram is going to be 12 inches
plus 8 inches plus 12 inches plus 8
inches 12 inches plus 8 inches plus 12
inches plus 8 inches 12 plus 8 is 20 12
plus 8 is 20 so this is all going to add
up to 40 40 inches and we're done I
guess this is a very small field because
there's only 8 inches so it's used I
guess it wouldn't call it would be a
little plot of land a little
parallelogram pop plot of land anyway
we're done its perimeter is 40 inches